where are you right now Rebecca mr. Dan
Patrick right now I am walking outside
Arsenal Stadium at the Emirates in North
London heading back to get my scripts
and then up to the studio which is
inside the stadium
can you see a pub from where your
location is right now I just walked past
a pub around the corner right now I'm
just license lapse so no public they
don't worry there are plenty in the
vicinity okay how busy is it right
before right now now four hours or so
before game time yeah it's pretty busy
is quite a few fans milling around and
the scarf sellers are out the hot dog
vans are out everyone's kind of getting
ready but because it's a Friday people
are either still at work or in the pub
and then they will Stargate or something
really packed and it's been about three
hours what happens if you go into the
wrong pub wearing wearing the wrong
killer this is bad things happen if you
were here I would point you in the
direction of the wrong path just to see
because it would just be so fun
especially with an American accent even
more fun no in this area with this game
today I'll snow lesser you won't have
too much for a problem but if you walk
into the wrong pub and you are a
Tottenham fan you're walking into an
Arsenal pub not a good plan I give me
the cool underdog team to root for this
year oh okay I'm going to give you West
Ham United because they've signed a
really good striker Mexican striker for
tea chorizo his name is Xavier Hernandez
his nickname is Chicharito which means
little P long story
but he is when you strike at West Ham
United they're a very cool club they
play their football in the Olympic
Stadium where London 2012 was held and
their manager slabin village is like a
proper mod he's super cool he's got cool
hair car he smokes cigarette they just
kind of hunches over on the sidelines is
just cool so that's West Ham United is
who you've got a route for this season
but I thought I brought up West Ham - a
couple years ago and didn't we not like
their colours do they have like brown or
something now they're claret and blue
which is like purple and blue and we
like their colours but back then you
were in love with Leicester City yeah I
shouldn't change a man who was in love
with Leicester especially with the
success that you had
I of course I called him lie sir City
when I said I really like this lie sir
City and you go you mean Leicester City
Dan yeah I like them too of my education
of you is like I feel like it's going to
be a couple of decades before we're both
on the same page we've got the Premier
League translation is I'm very proud of
you said Premier League rather than
Premier League I'm super proud of that
and now we're on Leicester but we could
we're getting there
season by season I just brought this up
to Paulie and he was stumped by this but
is it good or bad for the sport that
Messi Ronaldo and Neymar
do not play each other you know this
week to week in the same league if it's
good or bad for the Premier League or
good or bad for this for this for soccer
for sports in for the sport in general
yeah I suppose you're right there's a
kind of matchup of those guys is always
a real spectacle but within this a
nation there are so many players who are
getting to that level you know you've
got some wonderful players Philippe
Coutinho who Barcelona are trying to buy
for 100 million pounds it's edging
towards world-class status you've got
big big names across Europe levin dosti
another one you've got so many but but
every week there is a clash of top class
players no matter where you look in
Europe so I don't think it's too much of
a downer as long as they're playing then
football fans are happy
give me the favorite or favorites in the
Premier League
Manchester City are the favorites I
think to win the league with Pep
Guardiola who is some say the best
manager in the world
lassies and he underwhelmed a little bit
but he was very harshly treated by the
media this season I think he's going to
be I think it's gonna be feet under the
table a little bit more he's going to be
she's going to show what he can do I
think he's also spent about 200 million
dollars which also helps do you think
they'll ever be a salary cap in the
Premier League so you asked me that I
remember you asking down the first
interview I ever had a few years ago and
I was like no no no it's not it's never
going to happen that they won't allow it
to happen players are too powerful it
will change the whole way that the
transfer market goes and then it's not
at the moment in anybody's interest so
I'm going to say no the relegation
aspect is fascinating to me
when it when a team loses and has to be
relegated or somebody gets promoted and
what does that mean and is there a is
there a particular size your stadium has
to be to conform to the Premier League
now that you're going to be playing with
the big boys and the TV contract yeah
there is actually with Bournemouth so
now in the Premier League but for many
many years in fact for all of their over
100 year existence they were playing in
lower leagues they had to do a lot of
work on their Stadium because it only
held about 11,000 they had to have
people standing which you're not allowed
in the Premier League so they have to
install seats they have to do so many
things their stadium you don't have to
have certain size but you have to make
sure everyone has a seat and you're not
allowed to fans after the disasters that
have happened down the years and English
football with standards in stadiums in
terms of relegation/promotion is one of
the best things about English ripple and
about football across Europe relegation
can mean lots of jobs an hour sounds
like I'm saying is on the back I mean in
terms of drama and does it in terms of
drama it's funny because it means that
like people are playing for livelihoods
not just players but it's my class it's
about status it's about bragging rights
you know I have been known to shed a
tear that down the years when my club
has been relegated because it's just
it's a sad day but then the flip side of
it is that I've seen my club get
promoted and that is up there with the
best days of your life let me tell you
and it'd be if they brought that into
any form of American sport which I know
isn't going to happen and would be alien
at first I tell you Americans would love
it because they love the drama I would
love to see it too and and you know you
being a fan of Crystal Palace who would
be Crystal Palace in the NFL just to get
people you know something analogous to
what you did the pain that you go
through every year oh well let me tell
you have to tell me that because I've
seen my NFL knowledge whilst excellence
is the season a little rusty so if I
tell you that Crystal Palace are a queen
who are plucky not that good
somehow they above water but have a good
day every now and then who's that in the
NFL so kind of generic but you do root
for them because they they play hard is
that is that
that pair to say man what that be on
yeah um
maybe the Tennessee Titans I've never
heard of them dad why are you making
them something that I've never heard no
no no they're real team they're a real
team I wouldn't do that yes I promise
you never been on TV I've never heard of
it
do me a favor Howard maybe the New York
Giants know you could be the New York
Jets the Giants win they win Super Bowls
oh okay yeah all right off we get how
much betting goes on legally at the
stadiums oh-oh looks loads and loads and
loads I mean I'm about to walk into the
Emirates right now and there are little
booths everywhere William Hill is a is a
betting company that has it all sort of
desks you know every 50 yards or so and
then there are bookies on every high
street in the UK so there's a lot of
betting there's a lot of betting on the
mobiles I think the mobile-phone betting
is probably more rice than anything now
used to be that you turn up it again put
your 1-pound on the first goal scorer
with a man outside you're outside your
where your seating area was now people
just get on their phones and they do a
lot so yeah and it's legal but it's a
huge part of the game
can you put 20 euro on West Ham for me
are we cooking breakfast because if
we're talking breakfast I'm not
continuing this conversation
yeah euros just out yeah I I was going
to ask you that - sorry about that
sensitive to 120 pounds on West Ham 20
pounds on West Ham I'll put it on for
you I'll put off you by the way how is
Teddy doing how's your little boy Teddy
doing ah
Teddy is doing great thank you he is 15
months old walking around causing chaos
but here's is absolutely lovely thank
you for asking
will he play for the English national
team or the United States Navy I have
been asked that quite B times by
American people and um well if he's
really good
hey Franklin US Men's National Team all
will
I have to say that hello I have to say
that I work for a beauty if you didn't
work for NBC but you have beautiful
English yes the first thing of course
yeah hey have fun we'll cross paths I
hope during the season get my best to
the crew there and good luck today thank
you my friends love to everybody bad
fiction i Rebecca Lowe she's the host of
the Premier League on NBCSN the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience